Okay, we are recording and it is the 20th of June, I think, in 2018, and this Zoom calls
going to be an understanding histamine as we start to go through everybody's genetics.
This is one piece that we go through, and it's one piece that we go through a little bit
more adept because histamine can be a feeder of cancer.
So just to go over this again, so we are all on the same page, I also want to remind you
that when we are getting results back like results back on your genetics or results back
on your IVG test, I have put presentations together for the IVG, you will have to go to
the website, and you will have to click on the resources tab, which is on the top of the
website next to the store tab on our website, and on the resources tab you will see all our
blog posts, the IVG information, and how to understand what the IVG score means and such
is on a blog post, so search down, there is a search bar on our blog, so you can search
for IVG, and you will come up with that, but you can scroll down and you will see that.
Also when we go through your genetics, I don't want to go through the tests widely, I mean,
I want you guys to know what we are looking at, it will be helpful for you to understand.
So when we go through genetics, it is absolutely required that you watch some of the genetic
videos.
If you click on the genetics tab, the genes leave clues, I think, is the tab name, it will
on the bottom of that tab, you will see some other links to genetic pages, and now the Cancer
Genes book, which is a video book, it is not a written book, it is a video book, is up on
our website, on the bottom of that, the genes leave clues tab, you will see Cancer Genes,
the book, you can click on it, the book is a living book, maybe it is constantly being added
to, I only have done the first three sections of it, there will be multiple, multiple sections
as time goes by, so it will be constantly adding videos, the amount of time lapsed in the videos
that are out there right now are multiple hours of videos, I know that you are undergoing
your care here, or are you looking to get a PhD in functional medicine and genetics, however,
the learning as much as you can can be very helpful.
So at least watch some of those videos before we go over your genetics, so you really understand
what we're even looking at, it doesn't just all look great to you.
So some of you want to dirt out more, some of you don't, usually the ones who want to
dirt out more are on these calls, so we're going to just dirt out a little bit on histamine
today.
So histamine is important, so we hear about histamine because we see television commercials
about anti-histamines, and if you have a stuffy nose, a runny nose, seasonal allergies, can't
sleep, take an anti-histamine and it will decrease the histamines in your body so that you'll
be able to breathe fully and get rid of seasonal allergies, so that's true, well it certainly
can be.
The problem with taking a drug anti-histamine is it will reduce histamines, but then you
get a reflux secretion of more histamines, and it's really not solving the problem.
So even though I'm not against using anti-histamines at different times, if you have a long-standing
histamine problem, we want to address the reason that it's there and not just become depended
to put anti-histamines that can have all sorts of other side effects that we aren't going to
get into here.
So histamine, what is it, what does it do?
It's secreted in the body and it does numerous different things, the biggest thing we think
about histamine with histamine problems is the immune system because histamine acts as
a vasodilator, so it increases the dilation of the vessels and allows your immune response
to attack substance.
So what does your immune system do?
Your immune system kills things that are invading your body, like a virus or a bacteria or a fungus
or a mold, some living organism, a biotoxid is what your immune system is supposed to attack.
However, when things get into our body that are not supposed to be in our body, let's say
we eat a food substance that gets across a damaged gut border and that food substance
was supposed to be too big to get across a healthy gut, but because we have a damaged gut
border that food substance gets across in our immune system, fires a reaction, we end up
with histamine being secreted by these cells called mass cells in order to bring a more
immediate immune response there.
So histamine serves a purpose to aid the immune system.
Well, that's a good thing, but the problem is, is that your immune system is only supposed
to fire against biotoxins, living organisms and what it's firing against things like foods
or allergens that we are absorbing, that we shouldn't be getting into the bloodstream in
the first place, we have this immune response to things that are even killable.
So histamine continues to be up-regulated, it continues to be secreted by the body because
of the fact that these things are to be killed by the immune system.
So an example would be, my damage gut allows larger particles of proteins across its membrane
into the bloodstream and my immune system sees that as an enemy tries to kill it and because
it's just a peptide or a part of a protein, it doesn't die.
So it's constantly ramped up and you got this constant histamine reaction where it's continually
being secreted in a healthy individual with a healthy gut that doesn't take place, but when
we have a damaged gut, this is what takes place.
Histamine serves other purposes too, in the stomach it stimulates production of hydrochloric
acid for the preparation of digestion of carbohydrates.
In the brain, it functions actually as a neurotransmitter, it regulates sleep and actually helps you
get up, it's memory formation and brain arousal.
So it's similar to glutamate in the brain, it's an excitatory neurotransmitter.
That's why an antihistamine can help you fall asleep, it makes you drowsy because histamine
is a stimulant in your brain similar to glutamate.
So there are stimulatory and there are down regulatory neurotransmitters in the brain, histamine
is a stimulatory neurotransmitter.
Mass cells I already mentioned are what secrete histamine in the presence of the deed for histamine
which works on a negative feedback loop in the brain and in the stomach.
It's a secreted during a mastication, so you're chewing up food, that's your petalitis
released in your mouth and that stimulates the mass cell secretion in your stomach.
Well we always think of histamine as a bad guy but you gotta think of it as a good guy too.
So don't think of anything in your body really, that's created in your body as always a bad
guy, it's all about balance, remember.
So life is about balance, it's about having that right amount of something in your body
at every time and it is literally that out of balance that we have that causes disease.
And then you have to look at, so okay, is histamine the bad guy we're gonna take it into
histamine?
Well that might not be the right thing to do, at least at first we need to look at what
is causing this imbalance that is causing the excess histamine in my life, that's what
we want to look at.
So a couple of reasons where that might be, I started down the pathway to explain one of
them, it's an immune response.
And one might say it's an a baritone immune response, the immune system is overactive, that's
the problem.
Well it's really not, it's really a correctly active immune response.
The problem is that the immune system is firing against enemies that are killable.
So going back to our example of a damaged, gut-caused peptides of proteins to get through that
never should have gotten through.
So we got these things in our bloodstream that are not broken down completely, our immune system
is supposed to fire against enemies.
So it sees that as an enemy and it's firing against that enemy.
That's not an aberrant response, that's not an overactive response, that's a normal response.
What's abnormal is the damage to gut wall, allow this thing to get through that never should
have gotten through.
So all we're going to do is decrease my histamine response.
When we decrease our histamine response, we're decreasing our immune response.
So should a cancer patient take an anti-histamine drug, no?
But once in a while it's fine again, should anybody take it, once in a while it's fine, but you
got to look at the reason why it's there.
We don't want a chronic immune response because that's not going to be good for a cancer patient.
We want a good strong immune response, not this light up-regulated immune response that is
really stimulating T cell production to kill cancer cells, and that's what high histamine
levels will do over time.
So that's why it's important to look for the cause.
So is there an increased immune response, beating just that chronic, slightly up-regulated
immune response, increasing histamine levels that histamine itself, histamine is not a killer.
So histamine is not killing bad guys.
Histamine's purpose in an immune response is to increase fluid to the area, and vasodilated
by vasodilating the cells to increase the flow of immune system cells to the area.
The problem with cancer is that I said some cancers could then use histamine as a fuel source.
So we don't want a chronic inflammation, so that's what will be produced in this, is
a chronic inflammation that is simply up-regulated histamine, and not really giving you a T cell
spike that you want to kill cancer cells.
So we have to look at what's causing this, and that's where we get back to gut function.
And I'm using that as an example because that is so common.
Now there can be other reasons too, a person can have chronic biotoxins, I think I'm going
to slide on this, I'm getting a pet or my slides here, but maybe I don't.
So chronic biotoxins like a chronic Lyme or a chronic Epstee Bar or a chronic viral infection
that is just this slight and serious response that is stimulated histamine flow can be an issue
that we need to deal with that too.
So damaged borders, gut border, lung border, blood-brain barrier borders could cause this.
Chronic infections could cause this, chronic toxicities could cause this, that's slight
chronic ramped up immune response.
So these are the things that we want to look at, and these are things that can be then causes
for cancer and all sorts of diseases.
Dietary sources of histamine can be an issue, those are usually not so much the issue we're
going to talk about when they are.
But there's histamines that are contained in foods.
So we're not talking about dietary meaning a food allergy that's causing a histamine response
here because that will cause it too.
But we're talking about foods that contain a lot of histamine, cheese, eggs, nuts, fermented
foods, alcohol, aged foods, kombucha, things like that are high in histamine.
And when we look at your genetics that we'll look at in just a little bit, that's what
we're looking for, whether a person should be eating those or not, and we'll talk about
that.
So trying to gain that balance, how do we do?
It's really good to understand that when we talk about histamine, what are the things
that are stimulating that histamine response?
Remember, it's not so much that we're trying to get rid of histamine.
It's about that you, it's a good way to think about it is that you have a bucket and you
create, you know, you create histamine through your body, through different sources and
you get it in your foods through all sorts of things more than that are on this list.
And if that bucket is filled up and it overflows, that's when we're out of balance and it causes
problems.
Now, that bucket is never supposed to overflow because you have a failsafe method in your
genetics.
So you have a way to get rid of histamine.
So just like anything else in your body, you have these metabolic pathways.
You create a substance that has a purpose like histamine, it's great purpose, it's a neurotransmitter,
as helping create hydrochloric acid in your stomach, as vasodilation to get an immune response
to tissues, all these wonderful purposes.
But then you have these genes that help get rid of it.
The HNMT gene, maybe the more important of these, there's a number of genes in this family,
are the genes that created enzyme.
So remember, what do genes do?
Most genes are the purposes to create an enzyme and that enzyme that acts on the local tissue
or on a distant tissue and that's how it has its function.
The HNMT gene and the ABP1 family of genes create the enzyme called DAO.
That DAO enzyme is what breaks down histamine.
So when we look at your genes, we're looking at this right here.
Actually, there's a little bit more than these, but I just took this little snippet out.
So the ABP1 genes, if the person, remember, if we look at genes like this person has no defect
on this ABP1 gene, then on this one, they have a single allele defect.
The HNMT gene, this person, is pretty toast because they have a 2, 2, 2, 2 out of these
genes.
They have a number of homogenous or doubly old defects of these genes, meaning that the
gene is not going to work at all, but it's not going to work quite as well as if you did
not have a defect.
So this particular individual with genes like this, they have a more difficult time making
the DAO enzyme in the tissue.
Therefore, they'll have a more difficult time clearing histamine from the tissue.
The ABP1 gene is responsible for making the DAO enzyme mostly, mainly in the gut.
So digesting the histamines that they're consuming, this person a 1 and a 1 probably doesn't
have much problem with the tummy ache after they eat kombucha or a high histamine meal, but
they might have problems with airborne allergies, might have problems with rashes.
If they get a mosquito bite, they tend to react a little bit more.
They tend to have more, quote, unquote, allergic type responses, maybe more stuffy doses,
kind of thing, because of these defects of the HNMT gene, they don't make the DAO enzyme
very well in the tissue.
So that's how we look at the genes when we are looking at the histamine genes.
We also look at other genes like the FUT2 genes, because this is really important for
God help, because again, you have to go back to the, why do they have this first purpose,
this problem, their symptoms in the first place, you've got to look, you've got to continue
to look deeper.
Not solely a genetic issue of what clears the histamine, but it can be what's causing
the ramp up in the first place.
So you've got to look at leaky gut issues that we discussed.
All these different things can increase chronic histamine levels.
So that's what you've got to look at for causes.
Now what do you do to look at for actually trying to take care of this?
Well, going back to, well, number one, you've got to heal the gut.
You know, that's why on everybody's laptop, you've got that video that you watched when
you were here about healing the gut.
So healing the gut is most important, reducing inflammation and finding out what's causing
the inflammation.
Do I have another food sensitivity?
Do I have a damage cut because of chemical toxicity?
There's just enormous amount of different possibilities there that we want to dig into.
Reduce histamine foods, especially mainly if you have those ABP1 defects, though this person,
I would necessarily reduce any histamine foods, but if a person did have a lot of ABP1 defects,
we would say that maybe histamine foods are not going to be your friend and we need to
reduce these right here.
And then using some pre- and probiotics.
That's why we put just about everybody on sunscreen because I have not really met a cancer
patient that has had, maybe not twos throughout their FUT2s, but a lot of FUT2G defects.
The FUT2G is primarily responsible for healing the gut and creating muterate and fueling
the gut cell regeneration and that's exactly what's in the sunscreen to help do that.
Using digestive enzymes, helping HCL production, helping breakdown carbohydrates, helping
breakdown proteins, supporting liver function, supporting phase 2.5.
All these things that we want to do that we are doing on very many of you.
And ultimately, it's for the purpose of reducing systemic inflammation.
It's just this chronic and serious inflammation that causes issues.
That's the heart of most diseases today, so that's what we want to look at.
What are some other things that are causative?
This is some things that are touched about different infections, H. Pylori, Lyme disease,
colds, parasites, and certainly toxicities.
You can't even if you're eating all organic, get away from toxic exposure, so that's why
we use some different products to reduce these things.
This is the DAO enzyme itself, it doesn't get absorbed, but it helps with the breakdown
of histamine in the gut, especially if you have ABP1 defects.
Body products like histamine, scavenger, curcumin, boswellia, anti-inflammatory products
are very beneficial, and the best stress reduction head kit is just to beg your head against
the wall, that's what I use.
But that's the idea of looking what fills the bucket, how do we deal with that?
One of the causes, why the bucket is overflowing, and to me that's the best way that you could
really personalize.